a terror suspect is being held without
bond after his arrest last month but not
before you know roaming freely
throughout the United States for two
weeks authorities say the man entered
the US illegally on October 3rd and days
after he was released Homeland Security
revealed he was wanted in his home
country for terrorist activities this as
a caravan of 7,000 migrants that was
headed for the southern border is now
stopped in Mexico according to sources
many are just too tired to keep walking
well here to react is Fox News
contributor and former acting ice
director Tom Holman Tom it's so scary to
think that this terrorist was you know
who knows coordinating with a terrorist
s for two weeks before we actually
caught caught him what is going on how
come with the terror alert so high the
fire alarms aren't going on for the
Biden administration at this
moment well first of all well this isn't
the first time this happened this has
happened before and the reason it's
happening is because the Bor is under
such pressure to process as quick as as
possible and release as quick as
possible because this Administration
only cares about the Optics of this
crisis if there's no overcrowding
there's nothing to see here so there are
an intense pressure that's why they keep
sending more resources to the Border not
to enforce the law not to secure the
Border but to process quicker and
releaseed quicker and mistakes are going
to be made but what concerns me more are
the 1.7 n God ways that's what scares me
more who are they you no one's going to
tell me not a single one of that 1.7
million Goda ways didn't from didn't
come from a country that sponsored
Terror we got to remember borto arrested
people from 171 different countries many
of these countries are sponsored of
Terror they've arrested 569 know as
people off the terrorist watch list so
you got to figure how many the 1.7 Milli
known God ways came from a country
sponsoring Terror you know Tom to your
point take a look this is the terror
watch list rest at the southern border
169 in fiscal year 2023 9822 15 and 21
you go back to the Trump years three6
that's you know I've had somebody say to
me before Tom come on there was no zero
in 2019 people have said is that is that
real like and now we're looking at you
know plus what was it
120 well it's more than that you know
you know what no one's talking about the
northern border you know FY 23 they
arrested 434 excuse me 432 people on the
terrorist watch list was arrested at
Northern border almost twice as many in
southern border no one's talking about
that people need to understand the
northern border the crossing up over
800% they got very few borbo assets up
there and they took 50% of them moving
to the southern border so the northern
border is is a huge vulnerability but
you know you know after 911 here's
people how do you know how do you know
after 911 we created all these databases
we the TSA nor fly list the FBI
screening database the Visa security
program we stopped thousands of people
from coming getting a Visa coming to
United States because during the vetting
process we found derogatory information
however if you're a terrorist today and
you want to come harm to the United
States you're going to take the ra of
leas resistance why you going to put
yourself in a position to be vetted yeah
through all these programs when you
simply get to Mexico pay the cartels a
little extra money and be a goway that
is what the scary thing is this is the
biggest I've said a thousand times this
is the biggest National Security failure
that I've seen in this country since 911
and is self-inflicted
no doubt well the Biden Administration
now says it's going to spend $950
Million Dollar on some border wall
repairs so you got to be feeling good
about
that this isn't I feel good about that
but people need to remember they want to
keep throwing money in this problem and
pay countries more money to create
opportunity zones of the country money
doesn't fix this problem it is a policy
issue all they got to do is brush off
the Trump plans reinstate remain in
Mexico Supreme Court already says it's
legal if they re estate and remain in
Mexico program they fix 80% of the
problem if they if they if they they re
restart the the third third safe country
agreements they could solve this problem
there is a plan in place Trump
Administration proved it illegal
migration at a 45 year low illegal
migration down 83 to 90% depending on
what month you look at there's a plan to
fix it we proved it all they got to do
is reinstate these plans and secure that
border but they don't they don't want to
do it because this is this is by Design
it's by Design and thank you for
pointing out that this is not a money
problem the Republicans right now are
still trying to attach border money to
Ukraine money and pretending like and
and all it's going to do as you said is
just give more money for the Biden
Administration to process more um
illegals in our country U Tom you've
always been such a straight shooter on
this issue we really appreciate you
joining us today thanks Tom I'm Steve
duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angy aart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis